whoa
jankies
[Music]
so I wasn't planning to do a video on
this which is why it's coming out on a
Wednesday I haven't done Wednesday video
since I put the tattoo Doctor Who
reviews on temporary pause because I
haven't had the time but I wanted to
talk about Velma
Velma Dinkley from Scooby-Doo and in
specific I wanted to talk about the now
week in a bit uh yeah about a week and a
half old news that she's basically
confirmed as queer now
and like I said I wasn't going to talk
about this because like there's a
bajillion think pieces and I'm like ah
film is gay it's confirmed woo and
obviously the push back to that some of
the outrage Merchants going absolutely
nuts as they love to do but I mean Velma
in general has just kind of been in the
in the conversation thanks to the uh
show that is being done over on HBO for
an adult oriented one which honestly
probably would not have created much of
an uproar if that one ends up having any
kind of queer leanings because it's
already off-canon for being adult with
swearing and some other stuff that just
isn't standard so that you could already
accept that as not canon whereas this
you're
[Music]
this is a standard Scooby-Doo movie
trick or treat Scooby-Doo it's a
standard Scooby-Doo movie it's the
normal format it's Canon the cute ones
right Esteban well as Canon as anything
is Scooby-Doo related is it's a very
loose cannon she's shown very clearly to
have some very strong Crush responses to
a supporting antagonist character of
Coco Diablo okay who am I kidding I'm
crushing Big Time Daphne what do I do
what do I say
it's kind of hard to argue and Velma is
gay
there's a lot of responses to this as I
said some people are angry or feigning
outrage in a lot of cases I swear there
are some people like they've made their
entire online presence and or sometimes
their career out of just being
unreasonably angry about
well any diversity whatsoever
so I want to set those people aside
because
I prefer to not address them or their uh
claims or concerns because I find them
to be invalid and hateful
99.99999 and nine percent of the time I
don't even know why I'm offering up that
sliver of a possibility that maybe
sometimes they're not but I don't know
I'm feeling generous today
instead there's kind of an odd reaction
from some members of the queer Community
basically going
yeah we all kind of assumed she's gay we
kind of claimed her as part of our
community anyway like this is fine but
like why is this a big deal
well it is a big deal
and I think it's worth remembering why
even though it has been rumored parodied
accepted as a lot of people's Canon the
intention as flatly stated by some of
the creators of some official Scooby-Doo
media that they were depicting her as
gay as they were allowed to do despite
all of that
it's never beneficial and even with all
that it still matters that it is now
and I kind of want to talk about why
especially with yesterday having been
National Coming Out day
that's also the day I'm filming this
I wish I'd thought to talk about sooner
I could have gotten it out on the day
but here we are
so
why does it matter
why does it matter that a character and
a cartoon show who has been joked about
being gay and has kind of been accepted
by those who are prepared to accept it
or you know even derided that she was
already coded that way by those who
don't like it but as far as most people
were concerned they already seem to
think Velma was gay
so is this that big a deal
well yes
because when we live at an age when
there are
bills that pass in states that make it a
crime to bring up the very concept of
sexuality and gender outside of straight
heteronorms
then yeah
it matters that it can be said it
matters that it's not shameful it
matters that it's not a secret
and to anyone out there who's thinking
well look fine so she's gay do they have
to make it that obvious you know it's
not like it's not like straight people
have to go hey by the way I'm straight
well no they don't I've talked about
this before it's been a very very long
time if you go all the way back to the
video I did on Bill Potts on Doctor Who
if you are straight and heterosexual
you basically never have to declare that
because it is assumed
that is the automatic assumption about
the vast majority of people and for a
statistical majority of people it also
appears to be a correct assumption
but if you're queer then it's a false
assumption
and for all of the time that has gone on
with it seeming to be fairly accepted
within most of the fandom that velmo's
probably at the very least not straight
if not just a flat out lesbian oh and
like to be clear I do want to note this
a lot it's been reported a lot of places
like she's a lesbian like that we don't
know that she could just be bi let's not
discount that as a possibility
bisexuality is valid but like definitely
not straight that's for certain
but anyways
when you even have someone who is this
generally accepted as like they're not
straight
but if you can't say it if you don't say
it if you don't depict that and make it
clear
there will still be people
who will deny it
and they may even claim that that's
their right as fandom I don't want to
have to think about that I should be
able to enjoy this without thinking
about that
but stop and think about what you're
saying you should be able to do
you should be able to ignore
and willfully erase
part of someone's identity
for your comfort
and yes I know velma's not a real person
although she is inspired by a real
person and I'm gonna come back to that
but
she's a fictional person so like what
difference does it matter well
most people
have a lot of their understanding and
their feelings of queerness shaped by
the media they consume
and if you treat queer people in your
entertainment
as an intrusion
and you believe it to be your right that
if it is not shoved in your face it is
your right to ignore it even if it seems
blindingly obvious to everybody that is
you tacitly claiming
a right to ignore
an important part of people's identity
you don't have that you're not required
to be comfortable with it I would very
much like if more people were
comfortable with it but you're not
required to do that but you don't get to
erase it either
so one of the things that annoys me
about the literal queer Erasure in
history
I can and might even at some point in
the future do an entire video of how
many figures that people learn about in
school
and never get told that those people
weren't straight
whether it be William Shakespeare Walt
Whitman Alexander Hamilton Virginia
Woolf Alan Turing et cetera et cetera et
cetera Etc I brought that up on Twitter
and while a fair number of people have
response of like wait really and then
clearly seem to go off and look and do
it on their own others
um push back and like
from the list that I gave on Twitter you
know a handful of people were going okay
but I this one's not a certainty that
one's debated like arguing two or three
and ignoring all the rest and kind of
proving my point for me but some also
tried to say well like well what does
this have to do with their
accomplishments why do we need to know
that
because we exist in a world where
queerness is treated as an intrusion
on life because our place in history in
culture in fiction even
is willfully erased and so us
going hey we exist is treated as an
intrusion even though we've always been
here
because it is pretended as if we are not
and yes
I'm making that kind of point for a
fictional character like Velma but as I
said she may be fictional
but she is actually based on a real
person
if you did not know
the creators of Scooby-Doo were pretty
open about the fact that they ripped off
the not the full format of the show but
the character archetypes of the four
main leads from an existing show and
that's not the only thing they did that
with I mean The Flintstones just is The
Honeymooners it just is but in addition
to that Scooby-Doo is basically a
repurposing of the character archetypes
from a show called The Many Loves of
Dobie Gillis numerous characters in that
show were the basis for the main four
characters in Scooby-Doo the most
obvious of which being Bob Denver
Gilligan himself playing a beat-knit
character who was the bassist for Shaggy
this time tomorrow afternoon Dobby and
I'll be married
don't worry girl something to like
happen like what oh like something yeah
like getting married
this place is like blowing my mind but
the one I want to focus on is a
character named Zelda Gilroy Zelda
served as the basis for Velma now the
character of Zelda was performed by an
actress named Sheila cool Sheila cool
who is an open and out lesbian and has
been for quite some time now after
leaving acting she went to Harvard Law
School and then she got into politics in
1994 she became the first openly gay
person to be elected to the California
state legislature 2000 she became the
first openly gay person to serve in the
California state senate Sheila cool
is an awesome human being and she played
the character was the basis for Velma
did the creators of the original
original Scooby-Doo know that when they
reappropriated uh the general outline of
Zelda and turned her into Velma
no sure they didn't they might not have
used that character's bases if they had
but who cares
doesn't matter what they knew especially
for a show as reinvented as frequently
as Scooby-Doo has been
you had your original show you had the
one with Scrappy do you had the 13
Ghosts or whatever it was you had A Pup
Named Scooby-Doo you had what's New
Scooby-Doo you had Mystery Incorporated
you had the live action movies this
thing has been reinvented over and over
and over and over again and multiple
creators along the way the original
graders no but multiple creators and
numerous of these projects have gone
public in saying they either wanted
to depict Velma as gay and were
prevented from doing so or they at the
very least wrote her as gay as they knew
they could get away with because they
weren't allowed to say it
you know my favorite part about this is
there was for once
no
back padding no self-congratulation no
big enough it made the news yes but
there was no big build up this wasn't
the director of the live action Beauty
and the Beast talking about how there's
going to be an exclusively gay moment
before the film even came out the movie
just was released on October 4th
and there were the scenes of Velma
crushing so hard on a woman
so this stands as a monument not only to
allowing a character to be something
that like all of us kind of accepted
anyway but nobody had it nobody had been
allowed or dared to make it Cannon up to
now like just do it
let's do it
there's no reason not to at this point
unless you're trying to appeal to bigots
but it's not made for bigots it's made
for fans it is made for kids
and kids should know it's okay
to have those attractions
the people who get mad about this
wouldn't be mad if the exact same scene
played out but it was Shaggy crushing on
this woman
but they do because it's Velma
if one's okay the other has to be two
it does
either all sexuality is inappropriate
including heterosexuality
or
it is okay to show same-sex attractions
in children's media
you can't have it both ways but now
there she is
and she just gets to be
there is Velma
no big announcement no attempt at extra
publicity they probably knew news would
break but they didn't try and milk it
they didn't make a deal out of it they
just did it
see how easy that is
see how simple
it was
and by most accounts that I can tell the
movie's not even that good
but for the purposes of this doesn't
matter there's been plenty of bad
Scooby-Doo movies already there's so
many bad animated Scooby-Doo movies but
now there's one that just was allowed to
say hey
she thinks that girl's hot
good
thank you
thank you for
acknowledging that it's okay to say it
it's okay to show that
it's not shameful
it's not harmful
denying people's identities because it
makes you more comfortable
that's shameful
that's harmful
and Velma is really really queer and is
super crushing on that girl and you can
all just deal with it
I was a little combative at the very end
sorry
I get like I give very much experience
about this I get happy and then I get
annoyed when I think about why I'm even
happy about this because like the truth
is in a vacuum this shouldn't be a big
deal it shouldn't be
this should just be a thing that
happened
but it is a big deal because the context
in which it's happening because nothing
exists outside of context nothing exists
in a vacuum
and the society in which we currently
live that is increasingly cracking down
and demonizing
anything that is not heterosexual and
cisgender
yeah this is a big deal
and I wanted to acknowledge that
thanks for your time
um
uh apologies for supporters on my
patreon that I didn't have this up for
Early Access it was kind of very much a
whim sort of thing normally you do get
early access to most videos and if you
want to support my patreon you can do
that right there but whatever your
thoughts are on Velma and any of this
keep them respectful even if you feel
like disagreeing with me don't use slurs
or hate speech or personal attacks
because I'll just kill your comment
with no hesitation and no remorse but as
long as you can keep it respectful I do
want to hear your thoughts down in the
comments and let's talk about it
like share subscribe those help as well
but what I really want you to do
especially in the wake of national
coming out day
is that I need you to remember
whether you're out or whether you're not
whether you're an ally
if you're here
and you're listening
then you are beautiful
you're valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council is adjourned
[Music]
all right time to thank my highest
supporting patrons Robin Moore Zubin
fulla Tarak the theme that goes joint in
the anime Oliver B Melinda Walters emu
delki leotha Boyd toy lowly Becky Sparks
for nobelax the poodle Zach Bookworm
Tracy scrabot angry casperl Adam RDL
Taylor Shayla gourlay Brendan Larose and
TT thank you for your support if you
want to hear me try and say your name
while this little guy tries to chew on
my earrings well you can check out the
patreon or the support tears that get
you a shout out thanks so much you are a
pain in my butt
foreign
[Music]